this is a real smile probably blushing
too sorry world
so no things are good things are good
we're having a blast yeah he is
tara gal musa has no complaints on his
39th birthday
in an instagram post on friday the
flipper flop star reflected on how life
has changed for him
over the past year thanks to his fiancee
heather ray young
targ says he's got a second chance at
life
she just makes me feel really good and
happy you know
the birthday boy posted this family
photo of himself
heather and his kids taylor and braden
whom he shares with ex-wife christina
anstead
writing what can i say it's my 39th
birthday
my kids are happy and healthy and i'm in
love with heather ray young
i got a second chance at life i'm not
gonna waste it
love you all i'm so in love with tariq
and we knew from the very beginning like
we were gonna spend our lives together
as for the selling sunset star she
spoiled her soon to be husband
all weekend in orange county heather
also paid tribute to tarek in a loving
post
writing i am thankful for the universe
for bringing us together
we truly are soul mates and best friends
i must say she's
brilliant she's loving she's caring
she's supportive
and i just adore her heather thinks the
same about taric too
she called him the most loyal person and
gives her strength and confidence
i can't imagine my life without you i
can't wait to grow old together
kiss you every day and conquer this
world as a team
i am in love with you mr el musa i love
love i found my soul mate i
want to spend the rest of my life with
him the two lovebirds got engaged
last month while celebrating their one
year anniversary in catalina island
look at her hand yes she said yes the
future
mrs ella moosa anyways buddy she loves
the dog i love it
the hgtv star confirmed his relationship
with heather
in an interview with e.t last august
opening up about how she had turned his
life around
you know i just went through some pretty
traumatic things in my life and i was
honestly i was very happy and
comfortable on my own
and i didn't realize what i was missing
until i found what i was missing
it's like i was sad for a very long time
i was alone for a very long time
and i feel like she's like really
brought me back to life which is very
very fun to say and fans might get to
see heather and tarik's love life on
selling sunset
heather told et earlier this month that
if season four is in the books
it's possible that tarek will make an
appearance you know we might have a
special
um special announcement to make for
season four
if we get season four there's a
possibility he might be jumping on
so much of my life is tarik and i can
talk about him i think that's why i talk
about him so much is because
he is a huge part of my life um yeah
there might have been a deal made
so okay i mean fingers
[Music]